30 novembre
10h43 dimanche et certaines personnes
approchent d'un camion par l'entrée ouest n'ont pas le
temps de faire quoi que ce soit c'est le
cas de meurtre le plus médiatisé de l'
histoire britannique vous et Mlle Howe défendez
les terroristes accusés du
gouvernement et  vous êtes du New York
Times ils ne parlent pas aux journalistes
des procès liés à des questions de
sécurité nationale connaissez-vous une
raison qui pourrait nuire à votre
capacité à mener à bien cette
affaire quoi qu'il arrive quoi qu'il en soit je ne connais aucune raison
il y a des preuves contre vous qui,
selon l'accusation, devraient être gardées
secrètes du public et de vous, je
pense que vous vous trompez
Claudia Wendy a réussi en six mois,
notre client passe de la conduite d'un taxi à la
conduite d'une toute nouvelle Mercedes et
dépense deux mille dollars  une semaine d'où vient tout
l'argent des services de renseignement britanniques l'a
amené comme agent double, il était
censé les conduire à la
cellule terroriste avant l'attaque et c'est là
que tout a été fait  s'est mal passé avant l'attentat à la bombe,
il n'y a eu aucun contact entre le mi5
et les avocats de la défense accusés qui ont
posé le mauvais type de questions,
ils sont consommables plus d'un demi-million de
caméras en circuit fermé à Londres, je suis
sûr que cette demi-douzaine me regarde
bien  maintenant il y a des gens qui
veulent vraiment une condamnation ici,
j'aurais dû le garder hors du coup ma
vie je ne dois pas tuer des gens sur le
continent et qu'est-ce que tu as
un bon deux nous essayons simplement de
défendre notre
vidage client  votre sac vider tout sortir de
là maintenant il y a des pouvoirs de jeu que
ni vous ni moi ne pouvons même espérer
contrôler